It is time for me to scoop leaves. Would you like to help?
Sure!
I like a clean pond.
(Scoops leaves) And so do the fish!
Hey there! My name is Jessica Skye and I’m super excited for what we have planned today.
But first, let’s pause for a second. Can you hear my windchimes?
(Deep inhale - exhale) I love listening to that sound.
It always makes me feel happy and calm, and so many interesting things can happen
when we just pay attention to what is happening around us, and inside us, like with our breath.
Let’s try it together.
Remember that mat or towel you grabbed earlier? It’s time to roll it out on the floor.
Free to move your pillow if you need to.
And it’s fine if you don’t have a mat or towel, just find a safe flat surface.
Now, have a seat and get comfortable.
We’re gonna take three nice long breaths, in through the nose and out through the mouth.
Two more, and do it with me, inhaling (inhales), exhaling (exhales).
Last one, deep breath in, through your nose, heavy exhale through your mouth.
What are you doing?
Stillwater says if you have an angry feeling inside you, sit still, close your eyes,
and take deep, slow breaths
It can make you feel better.
Great job! Now, breathing is one of those things that we do all the time
and sometimes we don’t even notice it.
But, if you’re not feeling great on the inside,
taking a moment to catch your breath can change that,
and can really help you feel calm.
Is it working?
Actually, it is. (exhales) hhaah…
Are you ready to try something new? It’s called “deep belly breathing,”
and it’s one Stillwater’s favorites.
I like your big belly!
Me too!
I’d like you to put one hand, right here, on the top of your stomach,
just below your ribs.
And, when you breathe in, do it through your nose,
and I want you to try and make your belly big and full.
It’s like a balloon, and we’re filling it up with air,
and when it’s full, go ahead, and exhale super slowly through your mouth.
Let me show you and then let’s do it together.
Ready? Do this one with me
Feels good, right? Let’s do it a few more times together. Just keep going.
Super calming. One more.
Nice job filling up that balloon!
Very nice! I think you’re a natural!
Next, I’d like to ask what are some of the things you notice when everything is super quiet?
There are many different ways to be mindful in the world around you.
Let’s sit for a moment and just listen.
And I find sometimes it helps me focus if I close my eyes.
So, give it a go.
Soften your gaze, or completely close your eyes,
and just tune in with all those noises around you.
I can hear the water trickling behind me.
I can hear the birds chirping in the distance.
And the leaves rustling in the wind.
What can you hear?
Maybe there is a fan, blowing air in the background?
A car outside?
Maybe your family, in the other room, you can hear them.
Take a moment. Notice if you can hear your own breath.
Isn’t wonderful?
Now, let’s use our eyes this time.
Where do we start?
First, start with what you see. The shape of the fruit. The colors.
So, have a look around.
I can see pink flowers.
I can see green leaves starting to turn yellow.
I can see a red table.
What colors can you find around you, in your space?
What colors are the walls?
Maybe there’s an object on a desk, or a table? What color is that?
Maybe even look outside your window.
Notice what you can see there.
There are so many colors in the world.
So, take a moment, taking them all in.
Excellent job using your senses!
Now, let’s move on to something new!
Go ahead and stand up on your mat or towel, just like this
If you’ve got shoes or socks on, go ahead and take them off now.
We’re gonna give our toes something to do.
All set? Let’s scrunch our toes up and notice what we feel.
I can feel tingles on the tips of my toes.
What can you feel beneath your toes?
Is it soft?
Is…anything bunching out between your toes?
Maybe you’re on wooden floors, or tile?
Is it cold? Is it warm?
Now, let’s move up from our feet to the rest of our body.
Do you feel the air around you?
Maybe there is a fan or a heater?
And you can feel it blowing air onto your skin.
Or maybe you stood near an open window, and you can feel the breeze coming in.
Did you feel the cold on your back?
That’s my favorite part!
Perhaps the air in your room is still.
Try moving your arms slowly around you.
I bet you can feel the air now. Just notice how that feels.
It’s like the air is moving out of your way.
Just like ripples on a pond.
Alright, let’s do one more type of breathing,
and this is a fun one! It’s called “bee breath.”
That does sound like fun!
You know how bees make a buzzing sound?
That’s where this breathing gets its name from.
We’re gonna buzz together like little bees.
So, let’s take a slow breath in, through our nose,
and then this time exhale with the mouth closed,
and make a humming sound. Let me show you first.
Let’s try it together! Ready?
Feel how your lips vibrate a little bit and it kinda tickles?
You can even put one hand on your belly, like before,
and I bet it’s getting smaller while you’re humming.
Let’s try it one more time.
That’s good!
Now, I love how this makes me feel!
It relaxes me, and it also energizes me.
How does it make you feel?
How does your face, and tummy, and chest feel now?
It’s always important to notice how you’re feeling.
Both on the inside and the outside.
And, if you’re feeling happy on the inside, that’s wonderful!
And, if you’re not, that’s okay.
But, if you take a moment to breathe, it can make you feel a whole lot better!
Isn’t interesting how these feelings change when you give them time?
Thank you so much for sharing this part of your day with me.
See you!